what up brandon and theo fighter and
weight if you all use anything other
than bhl
your stuff's gonna be late now i heard
about these delivery drivers sending in
their videos
well i ain't down with brown and i'm fed
up with fedex and who are those new
dudes crying me in amazon river
shut up rookie i'm with that red and
yellow hitter
that pick up and drop off one hitter
quitter the 18 wheeler
six lane splitter damn anyways i got a
debate club for you guys
coming in barbecue you like that dry rub
on your meat that you feel in your feet
you like that barbecue sauce that'll
leave you at a loss
so dry rub versus barbecue sauce let me
know
shout out to my san jose girl cat meow
meow what's good
brendon you're welcome i came up with
buzz buzz back in episode four nick and
chin
pull it up give me the marker 4 30.
[Laughter]
you heard him boy apparently i'm making
a delivery to a proud boys convention
also buzz buzz came from theo in a rap
video about 14 years ago
well i don't know what happened but
let's throw this guy some credit this
guy has did a great job sending him a
video game
love the confidence yeah a lot of
confidence huh now when you see a man
like this
is this man that this man could be
mexican or he might not be mexican but
does he have that mexican confidence or
what
he definitely does he said i hate brown
so i'm not sure
but he definitely looked like he got the
confidence yeah he's talking about ups
no
i wasn't i was old then no you look
young as [ __ ] man
greetings canelo to the rat king and the
bee sting
gang gang buzz buzz it's your boy luis
from san jose
got a question for you king it or sting
it peeing
in the shower so that i think that was
the first time it was said on king of
the sting
he added that gang gang buzz buzz shout
out luis bro
thank you luis and look man i love dhl
man i invested actually i bought dhl
stock like five years ago or four years
ago and it [ __ ] tanked for me but
[Laughter]
but i love dhl man i like it when i see
you all out and about you know
taking that um taking a little bit of
that market share off of some of these
bad boys
[Laughter]
where'd you get it at i'll tell you
where i got it i keep going left
yeah very low point there left left left
left left left
right there left right there nope second
hill
right there and then i sold it go right
right there
[Laughter]
because i needed money to get my [ __ ]
car wash i remember
and then right around uh february like
i'm gonna get back in the game
[Laughter]
man they're panicking now i hope you got
shares of it man
uh what what's the question that dry rub
or wet sauce
oh dog i don't [ __ ] with dry rub listen
to the point dry rub
uh if you're in the club dry rub wings
are nice and that's
rick ross invented that lemon pepper
with the lemon pepper dry rub
i like my [ __ ] wet i like wet barbecue
wet ribs
wet brisket i like it wet daddy oh they
have wetlands
dude wet lemon pepper is my ultimate
favorite because what you do is there's
a food truck out here i forget the name
is a food truck
on my show matt barnes shout out to matt
barnes introduced me to them
it's a lemon pepper wet uh sauce and
they mix it with hot sauce
i'll tell you right i paid 10 grand from
the jt wings we had in phoenix
10 grand if i could get [ __ ] 100 of
those down my throat right now
i i i i don't know about that you don't
like wings
i like wings but i don't know about
whatever oh you would suck the um
okay well i will say this i think some
people are better at eating wings than
other people
really like who i think
i won the blazing buffalo challenge in
two minutes and 26 seconds i don't mean
[ __ ] though
that means you're just eating fat
buffalo wild wings oh this is a hot one
you're shooting fast though
you have no credit i think that's a
challenge though bernie does not like to
give credit to people
well but if we're not saying who can eat
the fastest wings it's like who can
really consume a wing like
my girl will eat the freaking cartilage
a chew on the the tip of it yeah it's
literally
just a bone chinese will do that is
there a girl's picture up on the wall
the roseville minnesota buffalo
wildlings
i don't think so you got a champion
you got you got that tank top bomb while
you're doing it i think this is the
first time in my life
you got a little bit of sauce on your
shoulder there buddy uh
baby unique do you like wings um they're
right i guess
[Music]
is